[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
delivering single molecule proteomics at
scale using protein identification by
short epitope mapping
i am marie stone of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by nautilus biotechnology
to learn more visit
nautilus.bio
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
parag malik founder and chief scientist
nautilus biotechnology
barag you may now begin your
presentation
hi everyone thanks so much for joining
us today
i really appreciate you taking the time
to sit down with us and learn a little
bit more about how our platform works
my hope today was really to
describe in a little bit more detail the
different aspects of the platform
our
thoughts and creating it and to answer
any questions that you might have
to really dive into the details
so we'll start off by just
taking a step back and from my own
experiences as a proteomics researcher
for many years
there
are many questions you might ask and say
okay well if we were to start over
if we were to say
instead of trying to
innovate or extend existing approaches
what might we want
our next generation proteomics platform
to look like what capabilities might we
want it to have
now i'm not going to
presume that our nautilus platform is
going to be able to address all of these
uh challenges but when we reached out to
proteomics researchers and said well
what do you want
there were a very compact set of
criteria that came up over and over
again
are you now able to see the presentation
yes
i did i didn't want to interrupt because
you were on a roll but go ahead
great um so taking a step back and
saying what would you want to see um
there were a clear set of criteria um
number one you wanted the
you wanted the platform to be
comprehensive you wanted to measure
substantively all of the proteins
we also wanted a platform that was
sensitive
ideally able to capture those very rare
proteins um that
that
you know were major drivers of biology
at the same time we recognize that the
scale of the proteome is very vast and
so being able to measure uh
not just extremely sensitively but the
entire range of the proteome
of course you want the platform to be
reproducible and robust
so that you have a path to the clinic
importantly you would want a platform
that can run very quickly so that you
can crunch through a large number of
samples and build those large cohorts
and really drive the biology that you
want to learn
and then importantly
ideally the platform should be easy to
use something that's accessible to the
broader biologic community
not just to
um you know the limited set of labs that
are able to
execute on very complex workflows
but of course building a platform that's
able to achieve on all of these metrics
is challenging um the
there are a couple particular reasons
why interrogating the protein is so hard
number one the protein proteins span
this incredibly wide dynamic range um
ranging from from uh
you know a handful of molecules to
uh to
to potentially millions or billions of
molecules
and that's particularly exacerbated
because there's no pcr for proteins if
you only had one molecule of something
in a sample you can't make more
and
on top of that you layer the challenge
the proteins themselves are
biophysically extremely diverse
large small charged hydrophobic et
cetera
and then each protein is not just alone
uh it exists in a wide range of of
states modifications ptms protein forms
etc
and so as we're thinking about these
challenges and thinking about how to
build a new platform
one of the clear opportunities was
potentially to build a platform that was
a single molecule platform
and so
what are the opportunities there well
one of the great opportunities with
being a single molecule platform is it's
definitionally as sensitive as it can be
if you're
measuring individual molecules you can't
be more sensitive there's no transition
to intensity or brightness
where there's a loss of information
another thing that happens very
specifically at the single molecule
level is that the challenge of
quantification itself changes
if i can identify each of my individual
molecules
identification becomes quantification
by identifying every individual molecule
i just count up those identifications
and that is my quantification
one of the other opportunities in a
single molecule platform is operating on
intact proteins
being able to probe proteoforms because
you're looking at at intact proteins as
opposed to digesting them where you lose
the contextual information of knowing
that multiple modifications or isoforms
and modifications are present with an
individual molecule
the other opportunity of course is again
just in looking at direct protein
measurement versus fragment measurement
is that some of the dynamic range
challenges that are exacerbated by
operating with peptides
some of the challenges and data analysis
and interpretation that arise from
peptide to protein assembly are
are naturally simpler on the other hand
you have a series of challenges that
have to be overcome
the first is how do you guarantee that
you're looking at single molecules as
opposed to sets of molecules how do you
actually both sensitively measure
individual protein molecules and do it
fast enough that you can have a wide
dynamic range
the approach that i'm going to discuss
today attempts to address these these
challenges
so
and really the platform has two
different pieces the first is a
sophisticated sample preparation
approach that
attempts to take individual molecules
from the sample
and array them out on a nano fabricated
chip in which each individual molecule
from the sample lives in its own
coordinate on the chip
this
and so we'll discuss that first and then
the second
piece of the platform
is an instrument and machine learning
framework that iteratively probes each
of those molecules over and over and
over again with a series of reagents in
order to identify and characterize each
of those molecules
so
as in building towards this platform we
have two big challenges the first is
how does one actually densely immobilize
individual protein molecules
on a surface
and then the second question is how does
one identify them and along the way
we'll talk about some of the
characteristics about the sample
preparation stability
potent
breath of the proteome etc
to try and answer some of the key
questions that you might ask
so diving in now to ask the question
about how does one uh
actually
densely immobilize individual protein
molecules
the way this is traditionally done is
using an approach called limiting
dilution in this approach you take a
sample you dilute it substantially and
then you spread those molecules out
again these are molecules from the
sample onto a surface now
what this results in is that the vast
majority of the space on your chip ends
up empty so about 90 typically
but
the loading is what's called poisson
loading which means that wherever there
is a protein
there are 50 of the time likely to be
two or more in particular
25
of the sites that are occupied will be
occupied with two proteins twelve
percent with three and on and on and on
and this is so this is sub-optimal for
two reasons one you're not actually
guaranteeing that you have single
molecules
it's also sub-optimal because you're
wasting a lot of space
with nothingness uh which from a
measurement perspective is then
inefficient one of the critical
characteristics of the platform is that
you want to be able to measure a very
large number of molecules
you get your sensitivity from it being a
single molecule readout you get your
dynamic range from measuring a large
number of molecules
just to go into a little bit more detail
on that
um
one of the questions you might ask is
well okay
if i want to measure the proteome um
just how many molecules would i want to
measure to capture the vast majority of
it in a single experiment though
one experiment you can do
one simulation is you can take the
distribution of proteins in the proteome
and you can
you can lay them out
onto a chip and ask the question how
many of them get deposited as a function
of the number of occupancy sites and so
we took
the currently known distribution of
protein abundances within
within a cell lysate um and then arrayed
them on chips of different features
feature amounts so whether 10 to the 6
10 to the 8 or 10 to the 10. and what
you can see is that there's a
consequence to that on the dynamic range
so if we consider the dynamic range to
being
the least abundant
protein to the most abundant protein
and then we also want to consider at any
given concentration what percent of the
proteins at that concentration are we
capturing you can see that there's a
sweet spot around 10 to the 10 that
allows you to capture substantively all
of the proteome
within a single experiment
and
and we'll go through in greater detail
you see this inset line here is talking
about what percent of those are actually
identified and you'll see that it's
substantively all at a given
concentration range so really the key
limiting driver is how many molecules
can you measure
so we wanted a platform that was able to
densely array a very large number of
molecules so they could be scanned
efficiently and quickly
the way that
and we discussed i've how limiting
dilution uh challenges that
now what we'd like to
go through now is our approach for how
do we actually generate these single
molecule hyperdense arrays um so
one approach in order to get super
poison deposition is to
is to try to make landing pads for
protein molecules that are very very
small
this is potentially challenging from a
technical perspective and so we instead
the team came up with a really clever
approach which was instead of trying to
make the landing pad small so you had
steric occlusion we instead make
the proteins large we do that through
the use of an intermediate scaffold
which is shown here
and so what you can see is a very
special nanoparticle that's been
fabricated by r2
oh dear
um uh so this nanoparticle is very
special it has ex
unlike traditional nanoparticles which
have hundreds of thousands of
conjugation sites this nanoparticle is
several hundred nanometers in dimension
um but
can only hold a single protein molecule
and so which is attached here at the top
of this flagpole you can see an afm
image of these of these particles here
um and so what we then do as our sample
preparation is we take our our
nanoparticles we take our sample we
functionalize them
uh we've
we functionalized the proteins with a
metal methyltetrazine group attaching to
either lysines or cysteines the
complementary group to that
methyltetrazine is on the scaffold
we mix them together and attach each
individual single protein molecule
to an individual scaffold
and each scaffold can hold exactly one
protein molecule
and we then
take those scaffold protein conjugates
and mix them with a specially patterned
array
so that each
scaffold protein conjugate lands on its
own landing pad and this
self-assembles uh
our hyperdense array so just some key
characteristics of the simple
preparation and i'm happy to go into
more detail in the q a
is that the the actual reaction time is
very efficient as well as uh the
chemistry is quite general
modifying the vast majority of the
proteome this chemistry is broadly
similar to the tmt modification
chemistry that is routinely used today
in proteomics workflows
but the use of the click chemistry by by
orthogonal chemistry allows for
a very specific conjugation between the
proteins and the scaffolds
just to dive in to look at what the
chips actually look like what you're
looking at here on the left is a very
small portion of one of the chips this
is about
1
100 000th of a chip and each one of if
we zoom in each one of these little
blobs that you see here is
one single protein molecule
a raid in a hyperdense fashion
the deposition itself is incredibly
efficient
so that the vast majority of sites are
occupied in the high 90
and and so
this allows one to generate very quickly
and efficiently a single molecule
hyperdense protein array which can then
be scanned very quickly when during
measurement
to demonstrate that we were in fact
getting single molecules
there is a very simple experiment one
can perform where one uses differently
labeled
proteins
add mixes them together and ask the
question how often does one see
two proteins of different colors landing
at the same
spot what you can see in this deposition
you have
one set of proteins in green another in
purple
and when you mix them together
for the most part
you see
only only one color represented at a
site in places where there are two uh of
these scaffolds co-localized um you'd
see a white dot and you see every now
and again there's a white dot um it's
typically under about one percent
if you'd like to
learn more about this method
the
a bioarchive
preprint
is available uh by axolotl
um
all right so just to recap the
sample prep workflow from beginning to
end uh this is
we would start with a typical proteomic
sample blood tissue cells
etc extract the proteins from from the
sample using traditional
proteomic extraction processes
note that we do not attempt to keep the
proteins
folded we typically use denaturing
extractions
we then functionalize the protein add
that methyltetrazine group conjugate the
proteins to their scaffolds
and then immobilize them on the chip
the sample prep workflow is is
relatively straightforward
and should be accessible to any lab
so switching gears
we now have this question all right well
when we've generated this hyperdense
single molecule protein array
how do we actually identify
each molecule
well
this is where the instrument and a
series of reagents comes in
so
there are really two different ways to
to
identify each molecule and we're going
to start with what is the general
workflow so in the general workflow
we're going to
immobilize our proteins
introduce a series of labeled probes
that
can either be protein protein-specific
if we're looking for proteoforms or it
can be our special class of
multi-affinity probes that recognize a
multiplicity of proteins these probes
are labeled with an ultra bright
fluorophore which allows us to image
where they have bound
we then
rinse away unbound material take a
picture and then wipe off
wash away a set of reagents and then
come back in and do this over and over
and over and over again
building these starry skies like images
of the data
some of the questions you might ask are
about just how stable
is the process and the proteins are are
again they are not
adsorbed
blindly to a surface they're covalently
attached to a scaffold which is strongly
attached to the nano-pattern surface and
so what we've seen over hundreds of
cycles is that one is able to
probe over and over and over again and
the proteins remain immobilized
the typical amount of protein loss
through a run is well below one percent
one point i'll mention is that we do we
have the advantage in our platform of
being able to use ultra bright
nanoparticles as
labels for our affinity reagents as well
this allows us to scan very quickly
because we are even though we are
looking at single molecule detection we
are not having to do single fluorophore
detection
this allows us again our entire platform
has been optimized for scale for
measuring a large number of molecules
quickly and efficiently
so
changing gears
what are the kinds of applications that
one might use this platform for and
there really are two very
different near-term applications that
we've been focused on the first is using
the platform for targeted studies
to really look at proteoforms and we'll
talk about that first and then second is
transitioning towards broad scale
detection
so as many of you are aware proteoforms
are critical drivers of phenotype
when we think about
regulation in the biological system
we start with dna we then
have are translated to multiple isoforms
and then decorate those isoforms with a
series of ptms so the proteoform is the
is the combination of all of those
isoforms and ptms and there may be
millions of these
critically it's been very challenging to
study the diversity of different
proteoforms um in particular
if whenev with any peptide centric
method
if we look at for instance these two
samples the one on the left and the one
on the right the one on the left having
one molecule that's triply modified and
then two other molecules that are
unmodified
versus a sample on the right where we
have three different molecules each of
which are modified at a different loci
from a peptide centric perspective if we
were to digest these proteins and
characterize the peptides we wouldn't be
able to distinguish these two samples
from each other but biologically they
likely have radically different behavior
and function this molecular
heterogeneity of proteoforms is likely a
major driver of biology
so
on the nautilus platform the way that we
address this question is right through
using a series of commercially available
position specific
and isoform specific reagents wherein we
will
immobilize our proteins and then probe
them over and over again
in again in non-destructive manner with
these
different reagents building up a
fingerprint
for every single molecule
to see what this looks like
we
as i said we have a series of different
molecules we might first probe with a
pan molecule to understand where all the
egfrs are for instance and then come in
with a position specific reagent looking
for 378 and identifying the molecules
that have that modification
wipe off our reagents come in again with
another set of probes that identify a
different loci and a different
modification
building up
over the span of five cycles potentially
interrogating as many as 32 distinct
proteoforms
to examine this in a real world context
uh we've been fortunate to partner um
uh with with a group of genentech to
look at the protein tau and in
particular looking at the relationship
between isoforms and
phosphorylations where there are a
series of different position-specific
reagents available
data from this experiment looks a little
like this where we'll have again our
starry skies a series of different loci
where we have proteins we'll then do a
detection experiment with for instance a
reagent that looks at
anti-phosphorus
tires threonine 181 and identify which
molecules have that modification we'll
then wipe off the probes come in with
another reagent that recognizes the 2n
isoform wipe it off come in again with a
region that recognizes the 0n and over a
series of cycles you are then able to
build up very detailed maps that say oh
okay this particular molecule is the tau
1n with a double modification on top of
it
really allowing you in detail to look at
the molecular heterogeneity of those
proteoforms for the first time
digging in we as one way to validate the
system we can control construct a
control sample that has a mix of
multiple proteoforms together
and then first probe each of those
individual proteoforms to make sure that
we are in fact able to get them right
mix them together and then demonstrate
that quantitatively one is able to
identify and quantify a variety of
different proteoforms all within the
same sample
changing gears
pretty form analysis is incredibly
exciting
and this method of identifying proteins
by going after them specifically is a
very powerful method that allows us to
use existing reagents particularly ones
that were
are used today for westerns but for
scaling to the entire proteome going
protein by protein would be an
inefficient manner and one of the points
that we raised early on was we wanted to
be able to go quickly
this brings us to the second piece of
our approach which is the really the
prism method
and in this method instead of go using
protein-specific reagents what we're
going to do is we're going to use a
series of special reagents which we call
multi-affinity probes which instead of
recognizing whole proteins recognize
very short epitopes typically three or
four amino acids long
now these probes are not in any way
protein specific but what we'll discuss
momentarily is that using a series of
these probes each one builds up a little
bit of information about each individual
molecule and the combination of that
collection of information is sufficient
to uniquely identify each molecule
intuitively
this is somewhat like playing guess who
with each molecule there are lots of
different strategies for playing guess
who one that's very prevalent is
that you can imagine is going and asking
of each protein are you tom are you joe
are you anita are you george
this
is a very inefficient method if i wanted
to identify somebody very quickly
on the other hand one could approach it
a slightly different way and say okay
well
i'm going to ask a question that's a
little more general are you bald for
instance are you wearing a hat are you
blonde
and this would allow me to rule out a
large number of people very quickly such
that instead of having to go one by one
and ask potentially as as many as 24
questions to figure out the identity of
a person
in one turn i might be able to rule out
half of the people in two turns
another half and three turns and so i
can very quickly and efficiently
identify a person
so with prism we use a similar approach
we ask a series of questions where we
say all right well
i have probes that have been raised
against a series of short epitopes i'm
going to
probe each individual molecule and
observe a binding pattern and then going
to ask the question computationally
using our machine learning layer what
protein is compatible with this pattern
of binding
and
in this case you can see that we've
probed with a series of these
the short epitope targeting
affinity reagents and our egfr protein
is able to be recognized
through a series of these bindings
whereas other proteins are incompatible
with this combination of affinity
reagents
just to go under the hood of the machine
learning we can see in this in this
animation or we can see in this plot
over a series of
of probings initially with a with a
small number of binding events
the algorithm is not entirely certain
what affinity what protein is present
but after about 10 or 12 it starts to
lock in and by about 15 it's really
started to figure out the right answer
which is the scrac6
and then from there on it becomes
increasingly confident that the protein
at that
landing pad is grax-6 and every other
protein becomes vanishingly improbable
one question you might ask is how many
probings are required how many different
affinity reagents are required in order
to
identify substantively all of the
proteome
um we know that if we wanted to do this
one protein at a time it would be on the
order of tens of thousands one of the
really surprising uh
results from these studies is is
being able to recognize that it
simulations show that between two and
three hundred probes is sufficient to
identify substantively all of the
proteome
one question might be
why why trimers instead of
tetramers instead of dimers versus or
something longer five six seven eight
amino acids long and the answer is that
tremors are really uh in the sweet spot
between
being able to tolerate
a
large number of
of off target binding events um
while being uh
small enough that each one is able to
deconvolve the whole proteome with a
small number of reagents what i'm
showing here in this plot uh is
is asking that question and saying how
many probes are required to measure 90
of the proteome
if one were to have probes that
perfectly recognized exactly one dimer
it's a really fantastic approach and one
could recogni deconvolve the vast
majority of the proteome decode the vast
majority of the protium with probably
about 150 probes however any cross
reactivity such that a dimer recognizes
uh you know has a wobble position
and instantly it becomes very difficult
trimers on the other hand have a very
wide range uh that um if if they
recognize a single timer or a range of
similar trimers uh 10 20 even 40
they're sufficient to to efficiently uh
crunch through the proteome
tetramers require much greater
degeneracy in order to
efficiently profile the proteome
in a smaller number of cycles
one question we got asked a lot is can
one actually build affinity reagents
that recognize short epitopes uh the
answer is we've put a lot of effort into
a series of different strategies uh both
on the aptomer and antibody development
side uh showing here a process of phage
display that we've been developing
internally um and the products of some
of those are shown down below uh where
we're looking at affinity reagents
against both tetramers and trimers one
of the things that you'll note is that
the ec50s of these are in the picomolar
range
and these are incredibly tight binders
and
that
just for frame of reference many
clinical antibodies
are not picomolar binders so
the first step that we will undergo is
we'll we'll do our phage display
processes uh to identify antibodies or
clx to identify um aptomers or other
approaches
identify a series validate that they
bind to their intended target but then
we go one step further and characterize
their off target binding as well
using a series of epitope mapping arrays
that allow us to detail in not just the
initial epitope that they recognize but
the family of related epitopes and this
has been really interesting
for instance one of the affinity
reagents that we use extensively which
was raised against the hhh epitope
actually binds quite well to a series of
related epitopes including hyh
and typically this would be a challenge
for affinity-based platforms but on our
platform this is actually an advantage
it allows for a given reagent to have a
broader reach and allows for potentially
identifying more proteins more
efficiently
one of the key questions of the platform
and one of the key attributes that one
needs to address is that this is a
single molecule platform with a
tremendous amount of stochasticity
consequently there is not a single
canonical fingerprint
that one might anticipate
it is likely that every single molecule
will have a series of different bindings
from each reagent and that the
combination of those bindings
really we're asking the question
given an observed pattern of binding
what protein is compatible with this
pattern of binding we're not
anticipating a singular pattern for any
given protein
this is why there is a sophisticated
machine learning framework under the
hood of prism
one other question that
may arise is just how sensitive is prism
to the specific set of targets and
affinity reagents
one might anticipate that there's a
singular perfect set of a particular set
of timers that one might go after and
that others might not be as effective
we investigated that question and found
that
that actually there is an optimal probe
set targeting an optimal set of
epitopes however even a random probe set
does does very well and so there's a
tremendous amount of flexibility around
what probes uh are used and what targets
are used in the platform
so coming back to our initial set of
questions
in building uh building our platform
you know when we started we discussed
wanting an approach that had a series of
characteristics in terms of being
comprehensive and sensitive having a
wide dynamic range being reproducible a
rapid run time
and the platform has been designed to it
with these
design criteria in mind
um in particular
the platform aims to deliver sensitivity
at scale being comprehensive being able
to measure substantively all of the
protium within a single experiment
it has been designed for single molecule
sensitivity it being a single molecule
platform really allows it to be as
sensitive as possible the dynamic range
comes from measuring a very large number
of of molecules and doing so very
quickly
the entire platform has been optimized
to be able to measure a large number of
proteins very very very quickly
the reproducibility and robustness it is
a digital readout
and
which contributes to reproducibility not
having to
think about the peptide assembly problem
and the variation that can come through
peptide protein assembly as well
helps support the reproducibility as
well as the ease of the sample handling
workflow
the throughput
again we've discussed that the
instrument
is efficient as well as the dense
protein deposition allows scanning a
large number of molecules very quickly
the prism method itself relying upon a
series of multi-affinity probes allows
one to measure
a greater percentage of the protein in a
smaller number of touches and then
lastly the platform itself is highly
integrated uh with a very simple
workflow both on the experimental side
and the computational side
to help ease adoption so
one last point i'll mention is that we
are hiring um so please do check out the
opportunities on our career page we're
always looking for great people to come
join the nautilus family so and with
that i'll pause and stop for questions
and thank you again for taking time out
of your day to come sit down with us
today
thank you parag for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started
our first question is
is the platform compatible with
non-human samples
yeah that's a that's a great question um
the answer is yes
the the method because it uses
these multi-affinity probes which target
short epitopes is fully general um to
to human yeast mouse uh any any protium
that you're interested in uh really the
only requirement on the computational
side is that we have a reference podium
a reference database available
all right thank you
next question
can the platform identify ptms in
discovery mode
yeah so so that's that's a complex
question so
the the platform is perfectly capable of
measuring ptms in even in discovery mode
um the
uh
the
through using for instance reagents that
that target uh pan-phosphotyrosine
the platform is able to look at and say
is there
on on this particular molecule um are we
is there a phosphorylation is there not
a phosphorylation is there a methylation
etc so even in discovery mode one's able
to look at post-translational
modifications now one may not be able to
fully localize those
to know exactly the position of the ptm
but you would be able to
ask the ask the question about
what percent of molecules are modified
phosphorylated methylated etc
all right thank you
next question
is there a limitation to the sample
types for which this could be used what
are the volume limitations
yeah so that's a good question
so far our plans for samples are to be
fairly general
so
cell lysates of any sort blood of any
sort um the
uh the the question of of just how
uh of how much material is used it is a
single molecule platform so it is
extremely sensitive so we we would
anticipate that uh
that on the order of below one microgram
of material um one to ten micrograms of
material should be sufficient um and
that corresponds to
a couple of microliters of blood um and
we of course are going to work on
pushing that down even more
all right
next question
how does sample multiplexing work how
many can be run at once
yeah that's a that's a great question um
the
the the i didn't show the architecture
of the flow cells but the flow cells are
arranged such that the set of flow cells
that are
inserted into the instrument uh have 12
lanes and so there's a natural way to
multiplex 12 samples at once
we also are continuing to work on
in-lane multiplexing to support even
even more
multiplexing beyond that
so um
so there there are a number of different
ways to achieve multiplexing to improve
throughput the consequence of course is
that there
the greater multiplexing you use there
will be a consequence on dynamic range
um we've heard from most people that
that the uh i should have mentioned up
front that the projected dynamic range
of a 10 to the 10 um
molecules measured is about nine and a
half orders of magnitude in cells and
about 11 and a half in blood um and so
most people are willing to
uh to
um we're excited to tran choose a
greater extent of multiplexing for the
nominal change in um
in uh in
in dynamic range
all right next question
does it matter how a sample has been
treated up front are denatured samples
okay for example
yeah absolutely so denatured samples are
are totally great um the one place where
uh there's concern about about samples
are for instance cross samples that are
extensively cross-linked um samples that
are extensively cross-linked may be hard
to separate into single molecules
and so there's a there's a challenge
there
however um
for other types of of of samples that
are denatured or are kept denatured our
current sample handling process further
denatures the proteins
so denaturation is totally totally okay
all right
next question
how long does it take in general to
analyze the data
that's a good question so data analysis
has a couple different phases
to it
one of the phases is
from an image processing perspective
things like denoising and deskewing and
down sampling the images to uh to a more
binarized representation of whether
there was a detected binding event or
not um that happens basically in real
time as the instrument is running then
there's a second step which is the
decoding process which is the matching
of
what given a pattern of binding what
protein is present
and that's a scalable process that
that
one can it's a known as a trivially
parallel process and so one can throw
more cpu at it too
to make the process uh
faster um
so we're anticipating on the order of
hours uh for for that step the
downstream analysis of course digging
into the biology uh that takes uh in a
varied amount of time as as all
biological investigations do
all right
next question how do you deal with
potentially differing affinities and
cross-reactivity of your multi-target
probes to their corresponding cognate
targets if this is too technical to
discuss here i understand and any
insight would be appreciated
yeah absolutely um so uh so i don't
think it's too technical because it's
one of the major strengths of our
platform um we do a lot of work
characterizing our probes to understand
what their affinities are what their
cross-reactivity profiles are
so i mentioned in particular
some of the efforts in epitope mapping
that we do
that's incorporated directly into the
algorithm
which anticipates that
that kind of cross reactivity
the differing affinities
manifest as a likelihood of a binding
event
again in a single molecule context
we you are recognizing that there either
was a binding event or was not and so
any given probe will have a given
probability of
binding to a given epitope
and so that comes from the upfront work
that we we do to characterize the probes
in depth
all right thank you parag do you have
any final comments for our audience
they i'd just like to thank everyone for
taking time um to
to to chat with us today if you have
further questions please do reach out
we're really happy to
to help uh
help ex clean the platform share the
platform with you uh really excited
about the potential for this platform
as a complement to
existing proteomics methods
for digging deeper and really for
getting to sensitivity at scale
well thank you again parag for your time
today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor nautilus biotechnology
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time take care everyone and
goodbye
you